my name's are Billy oh we know the
original head of qualcomm incorporated
in East Africa I want to talk about one
question that was put across and that is
how we can empower the african youth to
be able to become social agents for
change and i think one area that I'm
very passionate about is the use of
technology and we've seen that over the
years especially with the explosion of
the mobile mobile phones and the
adoption of mobile services in Africa
we've seen that Africans have become
very innovative in terms of how we use
the mobile phone in Toronto
communication being empowered right in
the urban and rural areas but I think
one area where as African leaders
business leaders as governments one area
that I think we can really put a lot of
emphasis on or put a lot of work on is
to create an enabling environment one
thats fast innovation and best pairing
innovation I don't just mean that we
come up with an environment which
encourages encourages innovation at a
later stage in life but a system of
education that right from the formative
years when the children is not going to
school we create you know curricula we
generally focus on areas of
extracurricular activities that can get
our children to start thinking
innovatively right from the time when
they're young people Albert Einstein say
that imagination is better than
knowledge what he was referring to is
that innovation really has a big role to
play in terms of empowering our people
and I think if you create an enabling
environment we invest in we need to look
at education systems in Britain an
education system that you know from the
time these kids start going to school
fine from going through the academic
curriculum which which is really
important in terms of them getting their
knowledge we also need to get these
people to start thinking of how they can
innovate you know look at their
environment start asking questions look
at what is offering every day around the
lines and be able to you know encourage
them to look at things out of the box
look at things differently so if you'll
take a lot of work because if you look
at the day of the most of the
educational systems that you have to
gain I find more of them a more academic
but i think if we make that shift in
terms of realizing that times have
changed you need to have a more
innovative ver society then we'll put in
a lot of emphasis in terms of empowering
these guys or you know they at the youth
to become innovative that will lead to
use of technology in a better way
because i believe that most of the
solution so I mean solution to most of
the problems that we face today or the
challenges I can place today and Africa
will default by us and one of the
biggest assets as you have today is you
know if you can build a knowledge base
that leverage
technology then we also be able to take
it to the next level to use technology
use I CD for example to come up with
solutions that a ball out of Africa the
relevant to our pecans and that
understand the African telling you that
race to the end you know if we give you
this they will be able to take this
forward and use whatever technology with
every innovation that they come up with
to solve the problems that we face today
thank you